Добрий день шановні колеги я вибачаюся у
Андрія Петровича в 3 години нарада тому
якщо я можу бути замість нього чимось
корисний Я готовий відповісти на ваше
запитання
тільки можна якщо ближче
наприклад
значить державна програма шкільний
автобус в цьому році по державному
бюджету
розрахована на 352 мільйони
відповідно в законі Про державний бюджет
Давайте я підійду ближче дайте ваш
мікрофон
і для всіх
учасників
352 мільйони гривень передбачено в цьому
році по державному бюджету в законі Про
державний бюджет кошти чітко визначені і
тому як кажуть просто підібрана вартість
розмір суми і кількість до кожної
області в цьому році
5 минут 5 минут
в цьому році ми офіційно на сайті в
січні місяці вартість автобусів була
403-404,000 грн
автомобілебудівники пішли нам назустріч
в нас на тендері автобус коливається від
3504 до 350 000 що майже на 50 000
дешевших Ну відповідно далі можуть 354 *
37 і одержати точну суму для
Миколаївської області якщо говорити в Ну
так би мовити мовою сухих цифр тільки
статистики то я порівняю за 9 років по
державній програмі шкільні автобуси до
Миколаївської області було 45 автобусів
в цьому році 37 це позитивна динаміка це
якість освіти
до начала учебного года на очереди по
графику все абсолютно 27 Регионов
Украины если говорить в цифрах то в этом
году одна из самых больших поставок это
48 автономная Республика Крым 40
жетоновская 41 Одесская Полтавская ну
примерно 37-40 машин в каждой области
э-э конкретная цифра это потребности и
наличие сельских школ где есть
необходимость учеников контингента на
подвозращита на поодинаковые формуле
головними управліннями освіти і науки
кожної Обласної Державної адміністрації
до навчального року 1 серпня закінчилась
підручники для перших та 11 класів чи
встигнемо до 15 серпня все-таки по всіх
регіонах
Ну ви знаєте Я думаю що це приємно є чим
тріумфувати ми закінчили в цьому році до
першого серпня друк підручників більше
100% для першого класу вже довезені в
області і
заприсяглися всі керівники обласних
управління освіти що до 10-го вони їх
доставлять до шкіл Зараз ми закінчуємо
довіз підручників 11-го класу і за
закінчимо їх повністю розвезення до 15
серпня Я вже казав всім вчителям і
керівникам районного що Якщо десь буде
затримка Ви повинні так би мовити
виймати душу витрясати з свого обласного
управління тому що все довезено до
областей буде до 10-го числа до 10
серпня місяця навіть якщо порівняти з
останніми роками Радянського Союзу це
найкращі показник і я сподіваюсь що за
другу половину серпня за вересень місяць
ми ще встигнемо і книжки шкільної
бібліотеки
це 53 Тома в сільській в основному школи
класика української
літератури і найкращі зразки світової
літератури російської літератури те що є
в шкільній програмі
спасибі